what about the manufacture and sale of a
a really good high quality Conan action
figure do you think there's a market for
that oh like that Deadpool when you just
held up yeah but also something that has
like movable wrists and like Kung Fu
Grip
well I mean Ben um you're the you're the
expert here but I'm talking about a
Conan O'Brien action figure it sits it
talks uh itself deprecates
um what what
do not expose to Sun for more than 30
seconds what would is there a market for
something like that and I want you to be
honest
I would buy it
well there's one he doesn't even want to
break the story you got one that's all
that's all you need you want you got to
start somewhere okay well feel free do
you remember the GI Joe figure Zartan
and how if you put it in the sun its
skin color would change they should do
that with Conan where you put it in the
sun and it just goes red No it should
start to smolder and then explode and
turn into slime
[Laughter]
um wow hold on let me let me write these
ideas down yeah well I think you're not
giving this idea uh you know much
credit I think if you and I had
spitballed a little more you might have
seen that there is a market for such a
doll you know and um I shouldn't call it
doll it's an action figure really and
then it could come with all kinds of
cool stuff comes with its own podcast
studio
um comes
comes with its own cholesterol measuring
yeah that that's an action figure more
than a little Lipitor that he's holding
it sits it talks it worries it's an
inaction figure yeah Ben do you have a
question for Conan and all
I do my question for you Conan is if you
were stranded on an island but you could
pick a toy or take a toy with you try to
keep it clean it's a children's toy to
keep to keep you to keep you busy while
you're just playing on this island there
goes my vibrating butt plug
you know if you did choose slime it's a
two for one just yeah
I've tried it and I do not recommend it
oh God going in is fine getting out is
not fun what did you okay well anyway
Sony you can just drop out if you can't
handle it you can drop out what if I
draw I would have well we're just
talking about inserting slime in our
bodies that's not what I was talking
about I'm not using it as lube I think
you started putting it in your body
wasn't that what you were talking I
meant it was I'm talking about something
I did four years ago
and it's still there no one was with you
on the sticking it in your body thing
every time I have a colonoscopy they
freak out I'm like what is going on up
here
it's so binding so binding and
brilliantly colored it's got
Sparkles anyway uh hey I'm gonna tell
you exactly what toy I would bring with
me I don't even know the name of this
toy but this is a true story
um when I was about 11 or 12. somewhere
around there uh my I came down Christmas
morning and Santa had left me this big
box and what it was was a styrofoam
aircraft carrier that must have been I
want to say about four and a half feet
long and it had a little catapult on it
and what you did is you put a little
plastic jet on it
and it had a wire system like a nylon
wire that ran up to that you could you
could attach to some part of a room that
was far away from you and it would shoot
it and this thing would ride up on the
wire and then it would turn around and
it would come back down and then you
would using a stick
you would guide it in for a tail hook
landing and I swear to God yes let me
see if that's it
is that it
oh man this thing was fun
I don't know I think it was flying Aces
mine was a jet fighter and I think it
was I think you did find it Gorly I
think this is it and maybe they're
variations yes I think they're different
but you would shoot it up uh you would
shoot it it would go up to the top of
the wire and then it had this little
simple mechanism that turned it around
and it would come back in for a landing
and you would use the stick and you
would need to guide it in to catch the
tail hook oh wow and it was really fun
and I remembered I used it so much I
played with it so much that it all
started to fall apart and I just kept
taping it up to keep it going but it was
an incredibly fun toy and uh be on the
lookout for that I'd love to set up one
here in the podcast studio
uh here at our little Command Center
Adam and I were just texting about that
yeah it'd be fun to do that do look into
this toy Ben it was really fun very low
Tech about as low Tech as a toy could
get but as you probably know sometimes
that's the joy this is before they were
putting computer chips into toys and it
was just very uh Lo-Fi but really fun